Now that my numbers have gone back into normal range, like PSA, calcium, bioclin phosphatase,
do you still recommend they take the cancer dose for eye-verbectin?
Which is this person's case 48 milligrams a day?
If so, for how long? And also do I need phymbedosol now? I am
able to get it in capsule form
Is the cancer dose based upon weight alone or something else to by weight fluctuates a bit?
Okay, so a couple different questions in here. Let's say, okay, so this person's all
signs
and
symptoms I believe for this person have shown great improvement. His PSA is a normal range, calcium's back to normal
phosphatase back down. Should I keep taking the eye-verbectin? Should I continue taking phymbedosol?
That is a you know if a person was talking about their supplements, I would say stay on it because there's no
negative effects of a supplement protocol
So why not stay on it? But there are negatives to taking drugs, okay?
Iverbectin even though it has less side effects than phymbedosol, it's still a drug
And your body could get used to it. So if your if your cancer has gone into remission
Should you stay on an Iverbectin and or phymbedosol protocol? Personally, I think no, I would cycle off. I would go off of them
And I would again retest everything in a month or two months or three months and if everything stayed normal, I'd stay off of them
So the reason is is that Iverbectin can have negative effects on your liver
So can phymbedosol? We just got done discussing that, huh?
We have even more severe negative effects
So if I was in remission, I would not be taking drugs of any kind. That's just me
Now there are other people like well, I want to stay there. So I'm gonna keep taking Iverbectin
I'm gonna, you know, go just pulse my phymbedosol
Everybody has to make their own decisions. Just personally, I wouldn't. So
This person had to say the question my answer would be I would go off of it. I would not take phymbedosol now
I just leave it. It's kind of like you're saving
More dangerous treatment
In case I need it
Besides the fact that a cancer could get used to something could you use to chemo and chemo then it fails and it's effective
Can get used to phymbedosol and Iverbectin so I would if I don't need it, I wouldn't use it
And then the second part of this question is
The dosage is dosage based on weight the dosage is based on weight only for Iverbectin
So Iverbectin has a weight dependent dose
Phymbedosol doesn't so phymbedosol dose has a ramped dose
That you start at 22 milligrams of active drug dose
per person three days on four days off
And then you can ramp that up in multiple different ways
By taking it every day or taking you know taking five days on two days off first things like that or double that dose for
44 milligrams just all sorts of different ways to ramp
Phymbedosol over again you would keep a close eye on your liver markers
Regardless of you if you're on the starting dose
Iverbectin's cancer dose is one half milligram per kilogram body weight to start dose
But in full answer this question I would pause both of them